hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're in
game number 10 of the 2018 World Chess
Championship between the champion Magnus
Carlsen and the Challenger Fabiano
Caruana we've already had a historic
start nine straight drawls in the World
Championship never has happened in the
World Championship there's only three
games left Fabiano has the white pieces
both today in in game number 12 if we
have a tie in points after game 12 we
will get some bonus chess in a form of
rapid and blitz
I think Magnus Carlsen definitely has
the advantage on that front since he is
the best fast chess player in the world
but we're going to get into it with game
number 10 Fabiana starting with the
white pieces pawn to e4 as he's done so
far in the past pretty frequently and
then pawn to c5 so Magnus Carlsen this
Sicilian defense as he has been so far
in the tournament Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and then pawn d4 at the beginning of
the tournament we saw Bishop to b5 and
then just two games ago in game number 8
Fabiana goes back to pawn to d4 after
the pawn captures Knight takes on d4
Knight to f6 Knight c3 and then pawn 5
this is exactly familiar to game number
8 the Lasker Pelican variation if you
remember from that the knight to b5 is a
pivotal move if you're not familiar
y-you can go back and watch that one but
pawn to d6 these players continue down
the same line that they did before
something you're not gonna see as often
as we have in this tournament feels like
they just keep playing the same lines
back in for trying to figure out when
the first player is going to play
something different thought it may be
Magnus Carlsen instead of bringing the
knight to b8 so we talked about in the
game before thought it might try Knight
to e7 instead continues down the same
line pawn to a4 Bishop here East 7
Bishop e2 Castle castle on the kingside
a knight here to d7 and then this is
where Fabiana decides to try something
different in game number eights
we're on move 12 now he played bishop
here two deeds
ooh getting ready to push with his pawn
this is protecting it and he brought his
knight back here to a3 but instead in
this game game number 10 he plays pawn
to b4 Magnus Carlsen at this point
seemed a little annoyed it took him over
10 minutes at this point to figure out
where he wanted to go up into this point
all the moves have been extremely fast
because they've memorized this game they
absolutely just played it so they know
every single thing that's going on and
usually especially if you've just played
a game your entire team has analyzed
every possible line going down so my
guess is is Hughes fairly annoyed that
there was not preparation from either
himself or his team for this b4 move now
after the game they asked him about this
specific position and he said it didn't
felt like it was terrible but was not as
prepared did not expect pawn to b4 from
Fabiana pawn to a6 forcing the knight to
move thought he would even play this in
game number 8 instead he played the pawn
to f5 after the bishop came here to d2
but we see pawn a six-night back to a 3
and then pawn down to a5 pond takes rook
recaptures in the knight to a c4 rook
protecting this pawn also threatening
the rook here on a5 so the rook comes
back to a 8 yes as a semi-open file if
you do control a file with your rook
typically wants to be something in the
center of the board because that's where
most sides are trying to control the
center so if it was on the c8 square
that's probably preferable right now but
does want to have somewhat control over
here because Fabiana is really starting
to look and pressure on the Queen side
of the board Bishop to e3 just adds
another attacker eyeing both the bishop
down on the Queen side of the board and
then pawn to f5 Magnus Carlsen
definitely needs to get some pieces
evolved into the action I have some sort
of attack
he can't just allow Fabiana to overwhelm
him on the Queen side of the board pawn
to e5 pawn down to f4 Bishop up to b6
and I really like this position from
Fabiana if you look at that at it this
is a great outpost from Fabiano all of
his pieces are very active he can get as
lights
bishop involved very easily as well he's
controlling the light squares he has the
most active piece right here on d5
because it is blocking so much of what
blacks trying to do it has this
backwards pawn on d6 and it's very hard
for black to get his light square Bishop
involved as an example this also blocks
the pawn here on b7 there's limited
squares where the rook from a eight can
get to so Fabiano has all the attacks
going on right now but this is attacking
the Queen Queens forced to come to e8
and then recovery if it does want to
swing over here to the Kings side it can
also once the Queen gets involved the
rook can swing over here to a1 you can
double up and start to push this pawn
over here on the a file Queen comes down
here to a g6 both threatening the pawn
on c2 but also just threatening this
pawn on g2 eventually you could see the
bishop come down to h3 this pawn is
being pinned down it's always good
practice to get your Queen on the same
file as your opponent's king bad things
can happen to your opponent that happens
even things like pawn to f3 can get
tricky depending on how White's setup
now Bishop to c7 just threatening this
pawn here on d6 yes the bishop and the
Queen are both protecting it but White's
just saying hey you need to tie up your
pieces to defend because I'm starting a
strong attack the knight and both the
bishop are attacking this backwards pawn
as soon as you get this pawn off the
board you can start to march up this D
pawn for Fabiano pawn to e4 and then
King to h1 this pawn here on e4 would be
a strong support for pawn to f3 that's
not something that Fabiana wants to deal
with he can see the pin coming
he knows the Queen's here on g6 we
decide to go ahead and play King to h1
as we analyze this board position Magnus
Carlson's in a tough spot I definitely
think Fabiano has a better position
how does magnus carlsen really get out
of this this pawn here on a5 is starting
to push up the board it is an annoyance
very active pieces over here on the
Queen side wants to be active on the
King side but it's tough for him to get
all of his pieces before white just
dominates on the Queen side of the board
and
sudden magnus carlsen comes up with a
completely crazy idea and it spawned
down to b5 giving up this pawn the
material says yeah go ahead and take if
you want now if you're not too familiar
with the move on pissant you can
actually take with your pawn he only has
one opportunity on this game this move
only to take but he can take right here
now the rook is going to come back if he
wants to take the Knights gonna take
right here then magnus carlsen could
play pawn to f3 and you can see pawn
takes Knight comes down here to e5 he
has a pretty strong attack out of this
he gave up upon the material but at the
end of that he has the attack he's
looking for the knight back here on a3
is no longer active in the game the
rooks have come off the board doesn't
have to worry as much about the Queen
side so Magnus Carlsen looking to give
up material just so he can have a
fighting chance and be somewhat
aggressive not not a passive move as
we've seen in the past now Fabiana took
about 14 minutes on this move you look
at this and you're just not really sure
how to respond you almost feel like
there's got to be something else going
on maybe if I take this pond bad things
happen so at the end of it he decides
not to take it instead he plays Knight
up here to b6 now the knight takes the
bishop takes here on B 6 and then Queen
to g5 this is probably another spots
where people who were extremely confused
when he played the b5 the entire
audience just went wild you can hear
them if you're watching the videos
because they were so excited but the
Queen to g5 was just as puzzling there
wasn't as much excitement because people
just weren't really understanding what
madness cross him was was doing here
this pawn here on b5 yes he played down
to b5 to just give it up to have that
advantage
but after Fabiana didn't take it he can
do something else to try to hold on to
it or just play something like
to be four now he's just opening up the
door for the bishop to take here on b5
and this is the best move for whites but
it almost looks like a trap if you're
Fabiano you're looking here magnus
carlsen took his time played queen to g5
something is going on why would he just
give me this pawn on d5 I already have a
strong attack over here on the Queen
side something doesn't feel right
Fabiana it took a long time
you know before these past couple moves
Fabiano had about a 30 minute advantage
but he took all of the time now they're
about even in time because he just
didn't know what to do at the end of it
instead of the bishop taking on b5 he
decided to play pawn to g3 at the end of
it they asked him about this position he
just said I felt like I should have
taken here but I just didn't know what
was gonna happen and I was running low
on time I felt like I needed to play
something a little safer he played pawn
to g3 so Magnus Carlsen poncy b4 so just
bettering his position each and every
time Manus Carlsen definitely has the
advantage in my opinion now rook to b3
just stopping the threat of the pond
continue to push down Bishop to h3 so
activating all the pieces rook to g1
pawn down here to f3 Bishop moves Bishop
takes on f1 Queen takes and then Queen
over here to d5 just centralizing and
taking that material here on d5 yes does
give up the pawn on b4 but he was
looking to give up that pawn a long time
ago now he has the two central pawns he
has a very active position you can see
his opponent here rook on chief one-hand
Queen on f1 is not exactly how Fabiano
drew this up especially with the king in
the corner and is it's really tied down
can't do much the pawn here on f3 with a
solid pawn structure here I really like
this position for Magnus Carlsen I think
he's navigated very very well
he put a bluff out there his opponent
did not call him now it's just a matter
of execution for Magnus Carlsen
Queen moves back to e6 rook up to be 5
and then Bishop to d8 and this is up
ition where I felt like magnus carlsen
just for some reason did not want to go
for and it's pretty disappointing to see
there's no reason to give up your darker
bishop if you have the advantage in the
game you don't want to start trading
down unless you have some massive
material advantage but both sides are
equal in material there's no reason in
this position to say yeah I'll just go
ahead and let's just trade off our
bishops play something else play rook to
c8 you know start to attack some
material have your opponent's respond to
that Queen to be one have them tie up
all of his pieces to defending rook down
to c4
this is both defending your pawn here it
can't be chased off by the dark square
bishop and hey this is going to give you
a better fighting chance
instead he plays my opinion a very
disappointing Bishop to d8 Queen here to
e1 and then we see the exchange on b6
pawn takes here on b6 now there's a
passed pawn for Fabiano rook to b8 just
stopping that threat Queen to e3
protecting the pawn queen down to c4
attacking the pawn right here as well as
attacking the rook rook swings back to
be to just defending both itself as well
as this pawn here on C tube rook to b7
opening up for the rook to swing back to
b8 just double-barreling right there
rook to a d1 just getting involved into
the center really just been hanging out
here on g1 not doing too much now it's
attacking this backward pawn here on d6
and then Queen to e2 another
disappointing move just says hey let's
go ahead and trade off material rook to
e1 do we do see in exchange right here
pawn to d5 pawn up here to h4 but this
is an in-game it's so difficult for
either these players to win there
they're so equally matched the double
rook in game with the same amount of
pawns and neither of the King is really
involved in the game so far it's gonna
be very difficult right here to get
anything but a draw King to f7 you can
see the Kings start to get involved into
the game and then rook up here to a6
there is one position that we
to where you know it's interesting here
as far as how Magnus wants to continue
if he brings his King to D for this is
tricky because he's now opening up the
door for Fabiano to run over on the
Kings side of the board if he doesn't he
pretty much admitting that this is a
drawing games magnus carlsen does fight
a little bit longer
he plays King here to d4 but then rook
to b5 stops that says yeah you might be
doing too much yes you could play
something like King here to c4 but rook
to a5 really stops it pawn down to d4
black doesn't have a huge threat here in
the game instead he decided to play rook
over here to d6 protect this backward
pawn rook down a4 King comes back says
yeah I couldn't find anything rook to
before King up here to e6 they didn't
play too many moves beyond that they
started to just moves the rooks around
exchange some material and then at the
end of the day yes Fabiano now has a
pawn advantage but this is still a drawn
game and so after 54 moves they decide
to draw 10 games in a row that they draw
I think Fabiano feeling pretty good that
he escaped this one magnus carlsen
although at the beginning he was
frustrated that he was not prepared for
that b4 move on a game number 12 felt
like he gave himself a shot said he
tried to go for the victory but at the
end he just couldn't find anything and
by move 30 you know you have the time
controls where you have a hundred
minutes for the first 40 and then after
40 moves you get an additional 50
minutes well 30 moves in the game they
both had 10 minutes left so while we do
look at this and say there's a missed
opportunity why'd he play certain things
there was some time control issues that
both of the players had to go through so
in my opinion they weren't playing
optimally for some of the time but
definitely would have liked to see
Magnus Carlsen fight with more of the
pieces instead of just raining down like
he did but tendrils we take a day off
tomorrow and then we come back for the
final two days Magnus Carlsen will lead
us off game number 11 in two days and
then Fabiano will finish this off on a
games
well for the normal classical portion
and then if there is a drawl again we
will have a tiebreaker thank you guys so
much for watching hopefully you're
enjoying the tournament and I will see
you guys in two days for game number
eleven